it's being built as an opportunity to
shape the outcome of the war in Ukraine
defense ministers from 50 countries are
meeting at Germany's Ramstein Air Base
to discuss the next steps in Military
Support for Ukraine top of the agenda
will be battle tanks and heavy weapons
which President Vladimir zielinski says
are vital to increasing his troops
offensive capabilities against Russian
forces
this new security assistance package is
worth up to 2.5 billion dollars
and it's one of the largest yet
it brings total U.S security assistance
to Ukraine to more than 26.7 billion
dollars since Russia's unprovoked
Invasion by its February
our new package provides even more air
defense capabilities to help Ukraine
defend its cities
and its Skies
and that includes nay Sam's munitions
and eight air defense Avenger air
defense systems
this new assistance package also help
helps meet Ukraine's urgent need for
armor and combat vehicles
the German made leopard two tanks are at
the core of the discussions at the
Ramstein Air Base launched in 1979
they've been upgraded several times
currently 13 European armies are using
the battle tanks The Leopard 2 is valued
for its maneuverability it's lighter
than other comparable models such as
Britain's challenge of two they've
recent Battlefield experience NATO
forces used them in Afghanistan other
nations that have received leopard tanks
from Germany require approval from
Berlin before they can be sent to a
third country that means the tanks can't
be sent to Ukraine without Germany's
permission Al jazeeras Ali Hashem is
standing by for us in Moscow Natasha
Butler is in key but first let's go to
Steph fasten who's at the Ramstein Air
Base in Germany where that meeting is
being held so step is Germany going to
send leopard to tanks or not
well that's still the million dollar
question here in Ramstein you heard
secretary Austin mentioning all the
weapon systems that are now being
pledged to be sent to Ukraine and the
aircraft defense uh all kinds of combat
Vehicles a lot of ammunition but that
one key thing that Ukraine really wants
and says it needs the leopard two tanks
has not been mentioned so far as a
contribution by Germany we know that the
German government under the leadership
of Chancellor Olive Schultz has been
hesitating for a month to send these
battle tanks because he is worried it's
called a game changer and he is worried
that it could lead to an escalation of
the war and it would actually involve
NATO getting into a direct confrontation
with Russia but the pressure here in
Ramstein and also in the weeks leading
up to this has been immense on Germany
and Austin has called it a decisive
moment for Ukraine and what it showed
was also that for the first time
Vladimir zelensky the president of
Ukraine has been addressing this meeting
here in Ramstein and he made a very
emotional plea he said time is running
out and he was basically pointing at the
hesitation by Germany and that it takes
such a long time to make decisions he
says we have no time to lose we are
basically facing maybe a next major
offensive here in Ukraine people are
dying every day so he was really making
an emotional plea but so far as I said
we haven't heard from Germany if they're
going to send the lap or two tags or not
there could be a compromise as you say
other countries in Europe have these
things as well there's around 2 000
tanks here of this leopard too and they
could say Germany could say we will give
you the permission to send them to
Ukraine but even that we haven't heard
so far okay steadfast and they're live
at Ramstein Air Base let's go to Cave
then Natasha Butler is there for US
president zielinski spoke to to that
that meeting of uh of foreign ministers
in uh Germany earlier uh Natasha what
did he tell them and what is it that he
specifically wants
well the Ukrainian President says that
he's hoping for some strong decisions
from uh this meeting in Germany look
what he wants is what Kiva said is
wanted all along it has repeatedly urged
Western uh powers to send more weapons
to Ukraine most recently more heavy
weapons things like tanks more armored
fighting vehicles but also ammunition
artillery basically anything and
everything that would help Ukrainian
forces defend themselves against Russian
forces uh what zielinski is saying is as
you heard steppers say is that look we
don't have time to hesitate because
every day that we hesitate plays into
the hands of the Russians he also took a
swipe at Germany for hesitating over
sending these leopard tanks at Olaf
Schultz decisions look as far as the
ukrainians are concerned they're like
look if you don't send these weapons
that allow us to fight the Russians you
will soon be fighting the of Russians
elsewhere in Europe that is the message
from Keith that they feel like they are
doing the work on behalf of other
Western Powers there's a lot of
frustration in Keith although there is
also a lot of gratitude for many of the
weapons that are being sent for example
we heard on uh Thursday that a number of
European nations including Estonia
Latvia Lithuania Poland the UK are all
sending more weapons to Ukraine uh large
numbers of weapons so Kiev is grateful
for that they know that the US is also
preparing this huge uh weapons package
but they say what they need is more
right now they are worried about a new
offensive by Russia and they need those
weapons as soon as possible that live in
Kiev let's go to Moscow then Ali Hashem
is there for us just as that conference
got under the way uh Ali the Kremlin
issued a statement in which it said that
Western countries supplying additional
tanks to Ukraine would not change the
course of the country conflict
Adrian the Kremlin also stated that the
NATO Summit and providing Ukraine with
more weapons is going to take this
conflict to another level this is what
dmitric the scope of the spokesperson
for the Kremlin said he also reiterated
yesterday's position by Dimitri midvedev
the deputy head of the National Security
Council who warned that Russia's Russia
losing the war means that this is going
to be a nuclear conflict and this is
kind of an escalatory a narrative or
rhetoric that the Russians are taking
and this also reflects in a way or
another the concerns here in Moscow from
the summit that's taking place or that's
going to take place this is changing the
the Dynamics and in a way or another to
Russia this is getting uh this is
getting a new factor into the in into
the battle and to them this is really
concerning now with respect to to the
Russian other Russian
positions the United the Russian
ambassador to the United States also
said that all Targets that are going to
be in Ukraine are going to be uh what
are all Western targets are going uh to
be hit by the Russians so it's kind of
escalation in the rhetoric however this
this concern is uh day after day taking
a new Dynamic here in Moscow how to
Serious Ali hash from there live in
Moscow many thanks to you darling